I'm Dan Abrams and this is our control
center at ami Network headquarters in
New York City we are gonna go right back
to Nikon T in a sheriff's office there
and seven other departments around the
country this is live PD dad how did you
learn about the cancellation of the show
I was informed about half an hour before
the announcement was made that this show
was going to cease production and I was
obviously very disappointed and
frustrated I've been fighting hard to
keep the show on the air let's jump
right into the hobby our Ambler case and
what happened that what was the process
for that footage so live PD was riding
with Williamson County deputies at the
time of that incident we were not on a
live show we were not on the air it was
during a hiatus but the cameras were
there and they followed the Williamson
County deputies as they went on the
pursuit with Xavier Ambler and
ultimately with the chasing incident I
never saw the live PD footage myself but
I've certainly seen the body cam footage
and it is obviously very troubling the
question that has been asked of live PD
is what happened to that footage and why
PD had a policy in place to keep footage
for a certain amount of time and then
not retain it and there was a reason for
that and the reason was so we wouldn't
become part of the story so we wouldn't
become an arm of law enforcement to use
us as a video repository or so other
attorneys could come and take our video
and use them in cases it was so we could
sort of stay out of the legal system and
just be chronicling police but now in
retrospect when you look at what
happened here
there should have been an exception for
something like this such that a video
like this should have been retained but
this was a following of policy you can
say it was the wrong policy but that's
the reason
that the video wasn't retained who set
that policy that was set by the lawyers
for a and E and for the production
company when was there an arrangement
between the police departments and your
show was there any kind of financial
arrangement did they get any way were
they compensated for no they didn't get
paid if if you know they had to incur
expenses I mean if we had to you know
pay for parking or if there was
something where you know somehow someone
endured overtime because afterwards they
had to deal with something those are the
only kinds of things where live PD would
have incurred that there was no payment
for their involvement in the show they
had certain rights with regard to
protecting undercover officers
confidential informants etc but in the
end we had the final say about what went
on the air at the end of the day is this
property dead now or will you try to
take it somewhere else or maybe do it on
your own it's not my property I mean if
it's really big fish the production
company I mean I'm a co-executive
producer but it really belongs to two
big fish and I don't know what's gonna
happen now
you know Annie has talked in its
statement about trying to figure out how
to recreate something but I don't think
we're going to see live PD as we've
known it again if you could recreate it
how would you recreate and what steps
would you take to correct what's going
on and and the systemic violence against
African America so first thing I would
do was I would make some changes in our
policies right I think that that we
should have shown this on the air
earlier involved a fatality and the
policy at the time was we don't show
fatalities on the air and it was
important enough as a news person if I'd
seen that video which I never did I know
I would have said we have to show this I
think that's the kind of policy change
that could be implemented but I also
think that considering what's going on
we
preparing to begin doing some real
outreach have some town halls talk about
how to incorporate this important and
productive movement into what live PDS
do what changes could you make though
and and as you look at the system we're
worth where where did that tape end up
how did that video
stop getting why didn't it get to the
highest executives involved with live
live again
it was just a policy that they had in
place that was adhere to and actually in
this case the Williamson County Sheriff
requested that live PD retain it because
in that the reason that live PD has this
window that they keep it is in case
there is a specific legal demand request
in the in the in the days after
something happens and that happened here
Williamson County asked that the tape be
retained while they investigate the tape
was retained in June of 2019 they inform
live PD that they had the body cam the
investigation had been concluded it was
at that point that the regular policy
that had applied kicked in and again I
wish that there were exceptions I am
heartbroken when I see hobby Ramblers
family speaking about their pain I wish
that I had the video I wish I'd seen the
video and could help in some way and I
understand that that can be frustrating
it and for some people it's almost
inexplicable the idea that that you
wouldn't keep a tape what do you what do
you mean what do you mean you're not
retaining it and the answer is no that
that came from a place of that know that
that know that the effort there was to
ensure that we didn't become an arm of
law enforcement and and in the end it
was the reverse here but that was the
policy
see it was not an effort to protect the
police in fact you could argue that to
some degree it was the opposite let's
say to protect your own behind would you
knowing that a case involved someone who
died and you had other cases where
people have died wouldn't you keep a
stockpile just in case of life
hey we were around during this case paid
this was involved and also understanding
that historically systematic violence
against African Americans in the police
department has been overwhelmingly shown
to be beyond and above well this is a
lawyerly like answer that I'm gonna have
to give you because it was it was a
legal policy that was in place and the
problem is the minute you start veering
off from your policy you then can't say
this is what we do across the board the
lawyers wanted to be able to say to
prosecutors and others who are subpoena
a video this is our policy we don't want
to be picking sides we don't want to be
and and you can argue there should have
been exceptions and the answer is I
think that's true there should have been
exceptions and I think in the end in
retrospect that was a mistake and it was
something that we had been talking about
before the show got cancelled on how to
change it and also we have to remember
that it the video doesn't take sides
because it doesn't lie and it's the same
with George Floyd the video didn't lie
it didn't pick sides it told the story
of what truly happened and that's been
the problem historically that there
aren't people there to actually video
because if it weren't videotaped there'd
be more police officers under arrest and
I think that's why live PD is so
important as a concept I think the fact
that we are filming police I mean you
know I was questioned today by someone
who was saying in criticizing the show
I've seen a lot of constitutional
violations on that show and my response
was the reason you've seen those is
because of live PD and I think that
that's important in terms of
highlighting the good and the
involving police officers how concerning
is it that the police off that there has
been this systemic violence in Police
Department and at what point did you
ever have a conversation with any of the
police departments that you chose about
what happens and what goes on in the
past see it's not our job to start
telling police officers how to do what
they do if we start telling them that
then we are now an arm of law
enforcement we are now part of what they
do and that was not our goal our goal
was to Chronicle what law enforcement
did was to document what law enforcement
did and in fact there were times when
there were people who are watching the
show getting angry that our camera
people weren't getting involved you know
an officer would be involved in a you
know a wrestling match some sort of
event with a suspect and people would
say how come your camera person didn't
get involved and helped the officer yep
I get that but the minute we start doing
that we're no longer there just to
chronicle it we are now participants in
the event you guys just got renewed for
a month ago for a hundred and sixty new
episodes and you were generally number
one in your time slot on cable
television when you aired how much of
that shows how much that Annie was
really disturbed that they pulled the
show that was so big
Annie was clearly under a lot of
pressure here to pull the show and again
I get it I get why people are angry and
people want change that's a good thing I
think we're getting better as a society
because of what we're seeing with a lot
of these protests but I also think
there's a risk of going too far and in
my view the same people who are calling
for body cams on police officers which I
support and I support the uniformity of
the use of them as well should be saying
that there's a place for
IPD they may say they want changes they
may say they want to see the show
different but the bottom line is I still
think that they should be also saying as
a place for life yeah III agree with you
and I hear what you're saying but at the
same time you have to look at in many
instances police are turning off their
body cams so that they aren't being and
so that they don't get criminally
indicted and they are also turning
around and just it disappears on a
regular basis so that's what makes this
case so interesting and important
because you had something and you knew
about something that was being basically
brushed under the rug
we'll wait but but the body cam footage
is there this is not a case where there
wasn't a body cam footage I mean they
have body cam footage your point about
body cams and this is why I said before
they need to be used uniformly there has
to be policies about how they're used so
there can't be discretion about when
they're used but in this case there was
body cam footage it's the reason again
I'm I'm confused as to why people aren't
angrier at law enforcement the district
attorney and some of the others who
didn't say we need more information why
are they just coming out now 15 months
later and saying hey by the way where's
your tape the position that live PD had
taken was we'll hold this we're holding
it there was no request and I get it the
answer is well why do you need a request
why do you need a request to try and you
know why do you need a request of a man
who died and you have the video of it
why do you why does someone have to
request that why is it your moral
compass saying let's hold on to this
because this could be a situation and
I'm not I'm talking about the moral
compass of the world I'd go a step
further and I'd say that if I'd seen the
tape when it happened
mm-hmm I would have advocated not just
for turning it over but for putting it
on the air which which would have
immediately drawn attention to this and
again and the point is this was not a
cover-up right I mean I get it that
people are gonna say well eighties
policy about not showing a fatality was
wrong okay
let's have a discussion the policy that
they had in place about not retaining
video was wrong again I think there
should have been an exception there but
the point is that this has been an
ongoing investigation before
oh well over a year and the first place
that people should be asking questions
of is the district attorney the other
police departments and others who are
investigating this that's the first
place to ask questions then come to live
PD kid and then I I hear you I just
don't think people trust the police
department because as we've seen what
about the prosecutor
I mean prosecutors haven't I mean in
many cases as we know and we could go
down a laundry list the prosecutors have
either under charged or over charged so
they can't convict and then these people
walk free and then there is a there's a
reckoning that happens out the only way
to reckon anything is out in the streets
okay there's a the belief is is that
there is a trust factor that we got we
can turn this but it better shot it what
I'm hearing is a desire for us to become
advocates advocacy look you're asking
for us to start judging that's not this
on the videos and therefore what we
should turn over to law enforcement and
you know what in the context of the
death of Xavier Ambler mm-hmm I think
there should have been an exception to
the rule period but it's not judging
it's being a human being not judgment it
is and again maybe I'm too much of a
lawyer maybe much of a lawyer and that I
married to a lawyer yeah yeah and I mean
that that I know the legal standards I
know the minute you start veering off of
particular standards and policies you
will pay a legal price but in the end
again and and I hope that whatever you
guys use for this interview that it's
clear I think we should have had
exception right I wish we had the video
I hate ya it's just that the legal
standard if you understand the history
of legal standards I mean you know we're
just we're just removed from the legal
standard
not being able to be both did you know
before that being 2/3 a man you know
there are a lot with a legal standard
that we're gonna there's only illegal
this and this is why I'm saying I
understand why Annie and big fish had
this policy yeah I do and I think it
came from a good place and yet I think
there should have been an exception I'm
sorry there wasn't I'm heartbroken for
the family
[Music]